>>> OUR WORLD LEAD BRI TO CITY
EURO'S LARGEST NUCLEAR POWER  ZI
THEY SAY RUSSIAN CLUSTER SHELLS
D EIGHT CIVILIANS IN A
THREE WERE AMBULANCE WORKERS WHO
HAD RESPONDED  T A PREDICTABLE G
DEPLOYMENT POINTR UKRA
MILITARYE,
ZAPORIZHZHIA UKRAINE SAY
CL
HMUTC ROBERTSON SPOKE
N THE
GROUND WHO WANT TO T
WHICH RUSSIAN
TR RETREATED.
>> Reporter: ATH O
UKRAINE'S MOST SUCCEFUOFFENSIVEN
OTH-MADE P CARRIER  BAKHM
MI EASTERNKRAINIAN K
TERRITORY FROM RUSSIANDER Y
ATTAC
LOSSES
RYIND AND CALCULAT AE D
ARMORED VEHICLES.
THIS TIMS
CHANCE TO R MIGHT AN
SHOW WHA'R YEVGENY
ON YOU TOOK
ITORY IS BECAU
FORCES RAN AWAY.
>> Transtor:IN IS I
O FL
IT IS HIS UNITS TH FLED.
AND  DUE TO
THE FAHABUT THE ASSAULT BY CIRC
E IS
BADMINUG
US WAGNERIRST.
FROM THEE, THREE YOUNG
TR RECALE
FI
YOU FEEL THE SHIVERS, ES SAYS.
EVERY D ,
MORTAR SHE T WF
WITH THEUCCESS, SS TOO
ALWAYS PAINFUL AND HARD
TO" .
EAF E BATTLEN'T STOPIT MAKS AN,
"AFTER ET MORALE GOES , UP
"YOU HAVE TO MOTIVAT
SOMEHOW."
ANIS LASLE NOT
ENUSSIANS WEREBACK.
ENTS.
NOT FOR THE T E
DAYS-LONG FIGHT ONNGECISIVE
EN.
STROY THE ENEMY,HEIR RESERWAY
EVEN AS
VEHICL WHERE THEWHICH ENABLED U
S FOR
STRI
>> Reporter: HISEIR SE OFIGHUSL
SAYS PRIZHS WRON
DISCOUNT THE RUS ARMY.SO THE OO
LAUNCHED AROUNOMND'TG
HOW SUCCESSFHI OF THE HAS BEEN.
SAYING WHETHER OR NOT IT'SCONNEE
COUNTEROFFENSIVE.
BUT AN
SSTR
GROU AD BAKHMUT AT
MOMENT.
JAKE?HAT'S UNUSUAL F PY THAT.
RIGHT.
.
SO
MEANWHILE, BRASH RUSSIAN WARLORD
AND WAGNERY CHIEF YEVGEN CAROFF.
BUT UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
COUNTRY NEEDS, QUOTE, A BIMEENS
UKRAINE HAS GOTTEN A NEW M
DELIVERY,  SG
DEEP INTRUSSIALD OCCUP
TERRITORY.
WHICH CNN'M SCIUTTO WAS T TOORTS
PREPARE TO LAUNCH MASSIVE NEENSW
A DEADLY NEW WEAPO THEIR
ARSENAL.
CNN EXCLUSIVELY FIRSRTED
THATIVERED
E IT KI
OF LONG-RANGE CAPABILITYV  BEE
>> THE DONATN SE WEA
SYSTE E BEST
CHANCE TO DEFEND THEMSELVE
>>DOW INIAN FORCES THE
RUSSIAA WESTERN OFFICIALAL A
PROP TO
RUSSIA'SGENGLIAN
HOWEVER,KRAINIAN FORCES HAVE
PLEDD E THE MISSIL
ONREIGN TERRITORY, NOTO ATTACK
WHILE THE U.S. HAS SO FAR YOU
REFUSED TO PROVIDE UKRAINE WITH
MSUCH AE
ATTACKEMS FOR FEAR OF SPARKING
RUSSIAN RETALIATION, T UK HAS
BEEN ME FORWARD LEANING WITH
ITS WEAPON SUPPLIES.
K PROVIDED
MODE WESTERNENGER 2
RE. DECIDED TO
SUPPLY ITS ABRAMTANKS.
THE AIR  STEALTHUISE
IT H A IEX5 MILES, THREE TIMES
U.S.-PROVIDED MISSILES.
COMPLEMENTARY HAUKRAINIANS ARE
G OFFENSIVE.
IT'S ABLE TO VIDEO IMAGERY
ALHAT
THEY'RE GOING AFTER.
STILL THE U.S. OFTA
UKY HAAT
NEUL.MATIONS THAT
THOSE DIMEIO NEED NUE TO BE SUS
UKRAIAN
VOLODYMYR Y,N
OTHER HAND,  HISIS NOT QUITE RE
G FOR AIY ISED.r: WE'RE EXPECTI
CLES.
AN ADVGOBEES.
OT
PEOPLE
I THINK THAT I
WE NEED TO WAIT."
>> Rep AS I GED TO ONLE MISSILE
UKTERRIT S, RUSSIA.
WE, THAT
IS VERY MUCHN OPEN TT
HERE.
EGALLY
ANNEXED BY RUSSI S
PONTIALLT K SOME O
RUSSIA'S MOSIZED MILITAR
EA ENTIRE CRIMEA PORT.
THAT CLDA REAL
PLANS THIS COUNTEROFFE